hey this is cole hauser i play rip
wheeler on yellowstone check it out i
love you
taylor sheridan has said from the very
beginning
that he had you in mind for rip what was
your first thought when you heard that
uh when he said that god i mean i had
him in mind too i mean i've been
watching it from a long time he's a you
know he's a phenomenal writer he's i
think one of the best american writers
right now out there
[Music]
what is your favorite part about playing
rip and do you do anything special to
get into the character maybe even
physically
i mean it's all of it really i mean you
know the great thing about rip is
there's a ton of different colors that
taylor's allowed me to play whether it's
you know obviously the the dark side of
him
the love the romance the passion you
know um the friendship the loyalty i got
whatever you want
you know all of it is is just what you
dream about as an actor so i've been
very fortunate in that way
with all that being said how similar are
you to rip
maybe less violence it's just a touch
yeah i'm gonna give you one last chance
you'll leave now or you'll never leave
there's parts of them i mean i i i feel
like the stuff that with kelly and i and
you know there's some moments in there
that
you know certainly uh i've been able to
you know kind of use from my own
relationship i've been with the same
woman for a very long time you're going
to spend the whole day thinking about me
[Music]
i do that already
what does your wife think of you kind of
now being solidified as
one of america's hottest on-screen
cowboys she doesn't see any of that she
is
one of those i mean amazing women she's
been with me for so long she knows the
ins and outs of what we do and she loves
kelly they get along great and yeah you
know it's it's a small family and she
comes up to montana so it's um it's
pretty easy what do you make of all of
the social media reaction to
the cowboys you have people who are
walking around airports and shirts with
rip on them and what do you think of all
of it
i mean to be honest to see again the
show and the growth of it and the growth
of the character and how it's kind of
struck a chord in america i mean it's
it's pretty amazing to watch people
dress up as beth and rip for halloween i
mean it's ultimately it's
it's been a wild kind of ride but very
cool to see
you obviously had to train to be a
cowboy how was that boot camp for you i
mean the first year was tough i mean
taylor is no joke i mean he put me on
every horse he could find that it was
frank you know he saddles different
saddles
[Music]
jefferson told us he has a scar and
sores on his booty yeah yeah
like i actually saw his funny when we
went to cowboy camp oh god you said i
actually saw i go you saw it
well i saw the blood running through his
jeans and i was like it's bloody goes
yeah i have saddle shores and i was like
oh man he's like you want me to look at
him he's like no
he went and sat in the river where are
you taking him pastor nine
there's way too much bear sign in this
pasture for me sir you guys all are
so much fun and and what i've been
gathering is it's like a it's a family
on and off camera
it is we've been together for a while
and obviously last year with covet i
mean we couldn't go out to dinner we
couldn't so we all went to each other's
houses and it was a little family that
that i love i mean i i'm honored to be a
part of this
how has it been shooting in montana
because it's absolutely stunning montana
i mean you know my family on my dad said
they're all from there so to do
something in montana for me has been a
big big deal you know and my family's
really proud of it so going up there
four and a half months out of the year
and being able to play and
go into the mountains and you know hike
and you know it's just been amazing what
is your favorite scene from season four
god that's a great question um there's a
bunch of them i love the scene with
carter when i opened the door and he sit
in there in that conversation about
about life you have no future
none
beyond this place i think it's
it says not only a lot of what
rip believes in but also
you know
the mentality that it takes to you know
to survive not only in life but also on
a ranch
life doesn't give people like you
chances kid if you haven't noticed when
you first read
that we were being introduced to carter
what was your initial reaction
great yeah yeah because you know again
it it just shows another side not only
with bath
rip and also the ranch and john dunn you
know and it's this new character that i
believe that you know is necessary for
their growth of their relationship as
well so i was very happy about it and i
like the way you know i've always with
what taylor is his consistency of
character and i think that the way he
wrote rip you know and carter is is he
gave him the ability to actually take
his time to get to the point of wanting
to bring him back to the ranch a full
circle moment too because it's he's a
mini rip in a way the thing is is yes i
think that moment where he's driving
away and he sees him in the rearview
mirror and he's by himself walking down
that road it reminds him of himself
[Music]
obviously beth and rip they're embracing
more of that maternal and paternal side
having carter around but they also they
also put this guard up still do you
think that their
perspective specifically rips
will change and open up even more to
view him as
a son and i know it's a big word but
especially because of what rip has been
through and how john took him in i think
there's potential for it i mean you know
rip you know as you've seen you know
throughout the years you know he's tough
love
and i think
the thing with him is it takes time you
know and i think that's just who he is
and
i think over time it might not be season
four it might be season five but you you
might see that i mean it's really up to
taylor and where he wants to go with it
now in season four
we see a lot of the wrath of rip
continue
there really is nothing that rip won't
do for john dutton is there no
that loyalty runs deep for rip you know
john is beginning middle on the end
other than beth you know and and the
family for that matter you know anybody
that was to to mess with the dutton
family you know he would he would take
uh
take out for sure you know you're the
only one in my life doesn't ask me why
when i say we're doing a thing
i figured you'd tell me why if you want
me to know i'll figure it out when we
get there i'm not calling you out for
rip
thanking you for it
talk to me about doing scenes with kevin
costner because you two
have been
together since the beginning yeah i mean
initially
you know he's somebody i've been
watching from afar for you know 30 years
and uh the opportunity to work with him
you know at first was was great and then
getting to know him and you know his
passion for not only acting but for john
dutton and the show you know was was
wonderful to see you know the lodge is
where family belongs
i mean you asking us to come live up
that's what i'm asking you know we've
become great friends and he's just a
lovely guy i mean he's from the same
hometown that i'm from it's actually
just down the road so we had that in
common and
you know he's like an older brother you
know it's nice to to look up to somebody
and see somebody as passionate as he is
i love you
i love you
i honestly think that beth and rip will
go down in tv history as
one of the most iconic couples you guys
just have such a profound impact on the
audience do you feel that way
you know i feel
like
beth and rip
you know
i think the reason why people i mean my
theory is is that you know they're not
perfect you know and they
they have their struggles they have
their issues and i think you know a lot
of the audience looks at that and they
you know whether they are having those
same issues or not you know probably not
as intense but i think that you know
they're they're they're uh you know
they're challenged in so many different
ways but they have each other and what
happens is when they're together they
open up so they get to see you know the
armor come off you're all i need
i'll call you whatever you want it's you
know wonderful to play it as an actor
and actually have somebody like kelly to
play it with
i mean she's fantastic but you know i i
think that's why they've fallen and love
is it's just not
that perfect like you know relationship
it's it's real
how would you describe your relationship
with her well i mean there's a you know
a freedom that we have together and i
think
you know
it's every once in a while whether it's
an actor or an actress that you have
that opportunity to really let the walls
down and have that
you know freedom to play i guess and i
couldn't ask for a better partner i mean
she has been such a blessing and um i
just hope that we get to continue to do
this for a very long time
she wants she also told us that she
would love to see some type of
beth and rip in the future when they're
like in their 60s and they're like you
know doing the same bet and rip stuff
and all of that in my rocking chair
you're you're rocking cheer yep i was
like pointing to people you do this you
do that the ranch comes first
and you forgot that
lloyd obviously there has been some
tension in the bunk house during season
four rip goes in there and puts them
into place i tell you consistency of
character
i don't care who you are you know there
are rules and regulations you break them
and you pay for them this is for your
protection lloyd you understand me
this is to protect you from yourself
so you have a relationship with 4j smith
oh i love the kid yeah
what kind of mindset it's easy because
he annoys me sometimes so i just okay
you know he'll be complaining about
something i'll just go okay let me just
tap into that and then i'll just throw
him around and he's pretty good you know
he's he's done the stunts throughout his
career and obviously he's a buckaroo
he's flown off a few horses so
he allowed me to throw him around pretty
good
so most of those scenes were you guys
yeah no stun doubles needed for fighting
though
i don't think they had a stunt over for
him i don't think so now
not that i'm aware of now look at lloyd
yeah
he doesn't get up very well he falls
down really good but he doesn't get up
very well so i always got to pick him up
do you read anything on social media
not really no okay no i mean
i i've been out a little bit you know
i'm i'm kind of secluded in in florida
and uh but uh i've been out a little bit
and seen the reaction and
you know it's
it's been wonderful that's all i can say
is people are genuinely you know
uh very kind and and guys and girls too
and now there's like a community yeah
between the yellowstone fans and there's
a reason why because the number one show
it's unbelievable
it's wonderful to go from the bottom all
the way to the top and to be there from
the beginning yeah yeah
it's you got to be very proud of it i am
very proud we'll just do it like the old
days
let's grab a truck where i can bring it
out here and we'll babysit them all
summer long now obviously the show is
very intense yeah but what is it like
when the camera cuts
and you all are just out there on set
together it depends on the day but you
know some days you know we're cutting it
up having a good time and you know
because we're on horses and usually when
taylor travis is there you know he'll
bring in like you know a case of beer
and we'll slide horses and we'll just
have a good time and he'll he'll shoot
it you know and that's
those are the the great kind of moments
that we all have as kind of a family you
know just cowboy and you know chase
steers and you know and just be boys i
guess and then you know there's those
days that you come in and the scenes are
extremely intense and
everybody's focused and they got their
game face on you mentioned some scenes
are obviously very intense and emotional
and there's a lot of tension
how is it for you coming out of those
very intense scenes
you know i mean i've i've done a lot of
them throughout my career so i've
learned to like i said turn the switch
on and off i've gotten better at it you
know over time but you know for years
and years it was very difficult to do i
mean you would drag some of that into
your you know into your life um you know
if you're playing a really evil person
so um but yeah i mean i think at the end
of the day
you know you leave it all on the field
as best you can and then you go home and
i have kids and you have to play dad and
uh husbands so right we don't go to the
train station
[Music]
one thing that is so great about this
season in particular is we're seeing a
lot more of the horses and what they are
capable of doing how cool is it to see
these sequences of the horses dancing
and showing off their skills and
in the ring in the rodeo and doing their
thing yeah so when we're on set
there's there's something that kind of
happens where it's like everybody starts
to kind of mutter and the next thing you
know it's like and everybody goes ooh is
travis here and that's taylor
oh yeah he's here and then you see the
bloomers come in
you see all these trucks come in and
boom all these you know millions of
dollars worth of horses come out and
it's game on are those all yours
[Music]
are now we're turning this into a
universe now and by we i mean taylor
sheridan yeah
yellowstone has become this incredible
universe with 1883 and the sixes spin
off coming what do you want to see
in the universe
i just want to see you know everybody
just continue to enjoy the show i mean i
i feel like look you know i think 1883
is going to be epic it looks epic
you know i'm excited to see where that
goes you know what he's touching right
now is turning into gold and i just hope
that he continues to pen yellowstone and
keep this train rolling who do you think
did the best in cowboy boot camp tim
mcgraw kevin costner or you
oh kevin wasn't in cow he did cowboy
boot camp like 30 years ago
for dances right he told me about it but
um i don't know i i just tim negron how
to ride so i guess the question would be
who's the best cowboy
i can't say that i don't know i've never
seen tim ride and yeah kevin's a badass
i mean i've gotten better over time but
it's taken you know the only thing you
can do is just work you know and
you know we'll see maybe we should all
get on horses together one day
do you have one horse that you
stick with well no so year two the horse
i love the most and he actually he's
lame now because he hurt himself not not
on the show but uh his name was dude
he was he was a bay horse okay and he
was a badass he'd do anything for me wow
yeah he was like my best friend wow this
is like rip and john but in horse form
yeah
you and i could look at him and go let's
go and he just walked right up yeah who
do you have now i uh they call him dude
number two oh my god there's dude number
three all the horses that i write are
named are just dude okay
so what's your relationship like with
those they're all good but nothing like
the first one
he would like come up and just snuggle
under my arm and pet him like just like
a normal pet wow and were you were you
good with horses before coming to
december okay decent i mean i grew up in
oregon
riding a little bit so but
but this has changed the game for me i
mean you know yeah having to play a
character like this you have to know
what you're doing so would you ever want
to see a bath and rip spin off oh yeah
is this enough room for you baby what do
you think
i'm gonna have five shirts and a pair of
boots but
you are the perfect man
why would you want to see this finna no
i mean i i would love to continue
working with her and taylor so yeah
that's why i say yes and i think you
know if if it presented itself of course
i mean i would definitely entertain that
more stories to tell yeah more horses to
ride you never know what her and i could
get into
we've seen taylor riding it could be a
really uh interesting
show
[Music]
you